this episode of the minimalists is
brought to you by your local Blockbuster
video store wait we got a sponsor for
the show finally
no I'm just kidding then this episode
and all of our episodes are 100%
advertisement free good enjoy the show
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without me
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalists podcast where we discuss
what it means to live a meaningful life
with less I'm Joshua fields Millburn and
I'm Ryan Nicodemus and together we are
the minimalist yes we are this episode
is episode number three and today we're
going to chat about children Ryan what
what did you do last weekend man I had
an awesome weekend I went to the hot
springs where to Jerry Johnson and we're
it was it was awesome there were no kids
there was all adults bathing in the hot
springs uh was pretty relaxing what
about you that's awesome and I was
chasing Ella around trying to convince
her to put her diaper back on who would
have thought that you have to deal with
a small child before I did not me um no
I for those of you who don't know Ryan
is certainly privy I I accidentally
became a parent by proxy last year um My
partner Becca Beck's
she has a two and a half year old
daughter Ella and so I am learning a ton
these days about managing children and
that's really what what today's episode
is going to be about and we're going to
start with what some voicemails yeah
that sounds good
yeah let's do that we have a couple
voicemails this first one is from dawn
hi guys my name is dawn and I am from
Columbus Ohio my question which I'm sure
tons of parents have all over the world
is how do you battle the clutter that
comes with kids I have two small kids
fair five and one I have a wonderful
family who I love dearly but when it
comes to holidays or even on holidays
the gift-giving is out of control our
book shelves are stocked full our toy
boxes are overflowing our basement is
full our house looks like a Toys R Us
from waterwall and I have guilt about
giving up things that don't belong to me
or things that have just recently been
given to them as a gift I feel kind of
mean I guess you would say if I try to
dictate the things that people give or
if I return things so I guess I'm just
trying to figure out how you feel this
third party clutter things that don't
belong to you things that people are
kind of inflicting on you so to speak
and what your solution would be to that
and this next voicemail is from Stephen
hi guys thanks for doing the show you
get episodes have been great so far
here's a question for you as I'm trying
to have a minimal life and whether
family and especially love a child and
we're in the society these days and cats
have adversity they have absolutely
everything in even stuff that they don't
even need but they feel they need up so
do you have any taps on the help in your
cat and also take on an animal life as
well
Thank You Steven and we have a similar
question also from a dawn this one's a
different dawn on Twitter yes Don Miller
writes at the minimalists I'm trying to
declutter with small children
neat helpful info for the influx of crap
kids bring on hashtag ask the
minimalists well we have we have three
similar questions here I think Ryan and
we started the first one with with
Dawn's yeah dawn she she brought
voicemail dawn yes the voicemail done
not not Twitter not twitter done this is
voicemail done no I think Don what's
that what stood out to me and her
question was how does she get rid of
these gifts and she specifically said
that she didn't want to get rid of
anything she didn't want to give away
anything because she felt very guilty or
she felt like she was being mean and and
Dawn I would love for you to read an
essay that we wrote that gives you
permission to let go of those gifts so
Don if you go to our website the
minimalists dot-com forward slash gifts
you will find an essay titled they're
letting go of physical gifts and you
know another thing too that might help
this situation not just finding a way to
get rid of the gifts but finding a way
to proactively get rid of gifts coming
into your home meaning instead of
waiting until December 26th and
regretting all of these presents that
you're getting and being angry at your
friends and family for gifting all your
children these gifts start the
conversation now start it right now in
January and talk about how you don't
want to bring those things into your
house and then reiterate that through
through conversation through your
actions through example throughout the
year yeah I think what Ryan's talking
about you're basically talking about
setting expectations right yeah and and
we need to do that beforehand what's the
saying you want to kill Godzilla when
he's a baby or as an egg don't wait til
Godzilla's taking over the city and I
think that that applies here too by
December 26 or the day after the
birthday or the day after the holiday or
whatever it's almost too late at that
point Godzilla has overtaken and then
you I think dawn on the voicemail said
that her house looks like Toys R Us and
I hope that
because there's like shopping carts
everywhere but she she has a lot of
stuff there now the word that she
mentioned actually she said someone gray
she said third-party clutter yellow I
love that term it makes me want to write
an essay about other people's clutter
and in this case the other people are
the kids and she mentioned guilt like
that well these things don't belong to
her well if they're your kids
technically these things actually do
belong to you so that's the first thing
to note is they do actually belong to
you you know I was at my my spine
doctor's office recently and I was
asking how was your Christmas and he
just sort of smiled he looked at me and
said you know I I had a minimalist
Christmas this year I'm thinking wow
this is a spinal surgeon and what do you
mean you had a minimalist Christmas and
he goes well my daughter's I got them
new beds for Christmas and we had an
impromptu packing party for my
daughter's room that his two daughters
are in a room together for those of you
don't know what a packing party is this
crazy experiment Ryan did you can check
out our TEDx talk if you want to learn
more about that the minimalists comm
slash TEDx I won't bombard you with that
entire story right now but he did a
miniature version kind of Orion did but
the thing that he did that was so
appealing to me Ryan is is he involved
his kids in the process so they
literally pulled everything out of the
room because they had these two bunk
beds yeah in the room and it was like
crammed into there he bought in these
loft beds with desks underneath and for
Christmas and there were these beautiful
things they really wanted and they're
getting of age now they're starting to
use desk and in order to do that in
order to accommodate that they can play
hit the rearrange of the room and it
made the perfect time to do an impromptu
inventory of essentially everything they
own and and the question that we have to
ask ourselves and I got this from our
friend Patrick Rowan we just finished
interviewing him for the the theater
crow cut of our documentary minimalism
and he has a daughter and a wife and the
question he always asks is is this where
this belongs
does this belong here and it was
interesting because I found that my
doctor was doing the same thing with his
two daughters going through each item in
the room and asking them where does this
below that's awesome that makes me think
of an attendee at our tour during art
100 City tour in 2014 god it's like so
long ago right
it was awesome though a phenomenal year
2014 example ten months on the road 119
events in a hundred cities eight
countries and got to meet and hug just
thousands of people's in general yeah
but it makes me think of one particular
attendee who talked about what they did
with their kid it was kind of this one
in one out rule and basically they had a
child who's in kindergarten in the first
grade they were doing a lot of art
projects and they always wanted to
display their art on the refrigerator so
it got to a point where the the parent
had to come up with something to help
teach this kid that yeah we can only put
so many pictures on the refrigerator so
their child would come home and you know
I would say mom mom I've got this great
art pictured that I want to put up on
the on the refrigerator and then the mom
would say great let's go ahead and put
one up on the roof go and put it up on
the refrigerator let's walk over there
together and pick one to take down so it
was kind of this one in one out rule
like yeah go let's go ahead and hang
this picture that you really really love
let's choose something to replace it and
then they would walk over to the trash
together and they would throw that away
so I thought this was really cool for a
couple ideas you know first off you are
teaching this this one in one out rule
with a child which is very very valuable
but then you're also teaching the child
to not be or to not attached or to
assign sentimentality to objects which I
know that there are many many people out
there who wish that they didn't have so
much sentimental feelings toward towards
objects and this is a great way to kind
of instill that into children from a
very young age
I'm really basically doing there is is
building this practice of letting go at
a very young age and you can't we Zout
that what that woman told you and apply
it to all material things not just the
refrigerator magnets or whatever you you
can have that apply to toys bringing new
things in means something else has to go
out and maybe doing what my doctor did
and taking an inventory after Christmas
and saying great here's all the new
stuff we're bringing into our lives are
you really enjoying this so in many
cases what I found
especially the LS she loves playing with
the boxes the things came in more than
she loves playing with the things and
and so you know it's really about well
what are the kids going to find value in
and and I think that by making them
question that and build the practice
you're not dictating you're not saying
well I'm simplifying my life so you also
have to simplify your life you are now a
baby minimalist which is the worst
approach I mean who if you came to me
Josh and you were like hey Ryan you need
to be a minimalist because you're a fat
loser and you got a bunch of stuff and
minimalism is gonna fix you like that
would not just say you were thinking
that hypothetically you wouldn't go into
someone and tell them that instead what
you would do is is you would you would
try to explain explain but but showcase
the benefits now here's the interesting
thing the benefits for me are going to
be different for Ryan in terms of
simplifying our lives but they're going
to be radically different for kids you
know the initial benefit for me was like
regaining control of my finances back in
the corporate world I had a great
corporate job and made well over six
figures but I had massive amounts of
debt because I had no control of my
finances and so what I found is that I
needed to regain control of my finances
that was a huge benefit of minimalism
for me now if I were to go to a a 2 year
old or five year old or a 7 year old or
a 15 year old even and say you know if
you get rid of a lot of your things and
stop being so attached to
cereal possessions you can regain
control of your finances I know if I
went to LSU would just like laugh at me
like she does about about anything else
right what our finances right and and so
what we have to do if we're trying to
expose simple living to other people we
really need to expose the benefits of
simple living not the how to piece but
the why to piece what's the purpose
behind letting go of that which is in
the way and what are the important
things that we're actually going to be
able to focus on keep in mind we're
letting go of excess because it's in the
way it's preventing us from living a
more meaningful life and that is true
even with kids having a super abundance
of toys that rarely get played with is
not a benefit it is a liability and so
yes you do need to set expectations with
others about gift-giving but do it way
before the holiday season because by the
time November rolls around people are
saying what am I going to get your kids
for the holidays by then it's almost too
late you can still put a stop to it then
but Godzilla has already grown up and so
we need to quash that well before and I
mean it's January now is a perfect time
to start setting expectations with your
loved ones and by the way if they're
going to give you a gift why not gift
experiences kids love experiences
whether it's you know some sort of
Disney on Ice Show or this past
Christmas we just went out and chopped
down a Christmas tree with $5 Christmas
tree permit they're all these
experiences you can do for kids that
have nothing to do with an influx of
crap as dawn on on Twitter talks about
so that's really where I'd start but I'd
also say this we got to let kids be kids
we have to remember that kids are kids
we interviewed Joshua Becker for our
documentary he wrote a phenomenal book
on this topic and so
certainly recommend it it's called
clutter-free with kids and you can find
a link to that as well as a phenomenal
essay that leo bob alta so Leo and his
wife Eva have six kids and they are
entire minimalist family and we
interviewed them for our documentary as
well he wrote an essay called no excuses
minimalism with six kids so you can find
links to that book clutter free with
kids and that essay from Leo that we had
him write over at the minimalists
dot-com slash children yeah just a ton
of ton of resources yeah there's a line
from Becker's book that really resonates
with me he said the rules of parents are
but three love limit and let them be and
he does a really good job of expounding
on that he gives really good tips and
tricks on how to not again tell your
kids what to do but to have your
children asking the right questions you
know another thing too I think would
help parents as well and Stephen kind of
mentioned this a little bit in his
voicemail where he talked about all of
the information in the huge amount of
advertisements that we get you know try
to going back to what Becker said limit
what type of entertainment your kids are
taking in meaning that if you're letting
them sit in front of the TV for eight to
ten hours I don't know what the average
kid or how much TV the average kid
watches these days if it was anything
like me was about six to eight hours a
day you know if they're sitting in front
of that TV they're getting no doubt
5,000 advertisements a day from the TV
and from everything else so if you start
to limit that you can start to decrease
the amount of advertisements and the
things that are kind of planted into
their heads 5,000 advertisements a day
that that's over a million a year easy
and it's amazing how we've changed so I
don't know Steven really talked about
there are all these things that kids
think they need they have to have and
well there's a reason for that
we spend what we used to say 1983 so
about 30 years ago we spent a hundred
million dollars
a year it's a ton of money on
advertising to children a hundred
million dollars to advertisers children
well today we spend 17 billion dollars
advertising to children then you can
look at it all over the place that the
most pernicious example is there are a
lot of these games now that have in-game
advertisements and and their impulse
buys like literal impulse you can click
here to upgrade your game spend ninety
nine cents here $2.99 there and man
there are parents that are getting bills
that are forty fifty dollars a hundred
dollars I mean there's some horror
stories Internet of thousand dollar
phone bills because kids are are
bringing this into their lives without
even knowing because they're acting on
impulse but guess what that's not the
kids fault kids are kids and they're
going to act on impulse because they
don't have the the frontal lobe to do
otherwise and and so we need to be
careful what we expose them to it
doesn't mean we can completely filter
out every single advertisement but let's
see what the children are watching and
act accordingly I know with with Ella
like we she's the only two and a half
year old I know that essentially gets a
no screen time at all right now it's
it's a big treat we will sometimes on
Sundays like breakout vexes iPad and let
her watch a video and and and so that
becomes a big tree but it's not it's not
a pacifier now here's the thing that's
really hard because yeah it's really
easy for me to break out you know my
phone and say yes here pacify yourself
with this leave me alone leave me alone
so I can go focus on something else and
not really pay attention to the person
who is right here and in front of me and
so I think we have to remember that kids
are watching us mm-hmm
and they're going to mimic what we do
they're going to act as if they are us
whether that starts with our words the
language we use I know all the time I
was so so freaking curious about
everything she's constantly asking why
why and you can't just give her a
simplistic answer you can to say well
because that's how it is because now
she'll just say well why because why
because and and then you'll give her an
answer but five minutes later she asks
the same question
and they're actually you know
psychological reasons for doing that
kids really want affirmation and
attention but but the the reason that
she's asking that is so we can try to
reiterate the story in a different way
and explain it to her but you can't just
say do you remember this thing I told
you five minutes ago often we have to
actually just reiterate the story and so
keep in mind the kids are watching us
they're they're paying attention they're
hanging on to our every word in many
cases and so we have to be careful with
what options that we put in front of
them either intentionally or
inadvertently and you know what I know
you say you feel guilty dawn when you
are getting rid of some of the stuff but
maybe the question to ask yourself is
what is my outcome and what do I want to
get out of this because it's not just
about getting rid of the toys that would
be really weird and sadistic if you like
I really want to get rid of kids toys
well no that's not the point your point
is you want to live with less clutter
and you want to not be bombarded with
stuff that gets used once or twice or
maybe three times if you're lucky and
then discard it and the junk bin and the
calls that our basement or attic or
worse a storage locker on the edge of
town you know the outcome I think most
of us want isn't getting rid of the
stuff the outcome is well I want my kids
to live a happier or more productive
life I want my kids to live the good
life and grow to be good people be
responsible people and I can tell you
you know this already the material
possessions aren't going to make the kid
a better person right
I remember you know we Ryan and I both
grew up really poor back on the
outskirts of Dayton Ohio and we were
discontented growing up and and I
thought it was because we didn't make a
whole lot of money but and we didn't
have a lot of things really that's not
why we were discontented we didn't have
Pleasant experiences growing up all the
time and so I can think back to some of
the few pleasant experiences for me I
had very few toys but every other
weekend after our mom got her her
paycheck she would take me to Big Bear
it was the the store that was you know
closest to us and I would spend hours in
the toy aisle trying to choose between
GI Joes and call it my decision down to
the specific decision on one toy and
that was our our form of entertainment
oh no it wasn't about the toy itself I
don't remember a single toy that we
bought but I remember dozens of those
experiences and and being forced into
decision making because we didn't have
the money to buy five or six or ten toys
and being forced into that decision and
making that a positive experience for me
shaped my my life for the rest of my
life and I'm still able to do that now
and because of that decision-making
process repeatedly I'm able to make
great decisions with my life now I have
good decision-making capabilities yeah
it's amazing how the choices can even
overwhelm a child I remember living
upstate New York where it was me my
three cousins that my mom and dad had
temporarily adopted and then my mom and
dad so there were six of us living in a
one-bedroom house my mom and dad
literally slept on the pullout sofa I
when I got really really cold we would
turn on kerosene heaters and like climb
in bed both on which by the way the
kerosene heater is like a most unhealthy
way to heat your house I don't think my
dangerous oh yeah I know I don't think
my dad knew that at the time but I
remember my grandfather
my momma check to say you know thanks
for taking care of my grandkids here's a
little bit of money to help you guys out
take the kids to Toys R Us and let them
pick out whatever toy they want and I
remember being so overwhelmed with all
the choices that it literally got to a
point where I was the last kid that
hadn't picked out a toy my mom was like
pick something or we're leaving and
you're getting nothing so like I grabbed
a bucket of Legos because they were
there and it was something that that I
thought I could get a lot of use out of
but but sometimes when we think we're
giving our children those those I say
our children like I have gauge which by
the way I understand how ironic this is
that Josh and I are talking about kids
you know it's interesting cuz we used to
get with we'd be on tour like like in
2014 or we did 35 stops in 2015 that
seemed like a blip compared to the
previous year right right but we'd be
out on the road and people say you know
do you have any tips for you know
minimalist parenting and we just caught
some kind of look at them and say ah no
no really because it was like hey here's
a couple at the time 32 year old single
guys who didn't have kids and it's easy
for you know single young guys without
kids to I say yeah hesitated saying
young we're still young right I'll take
it to give out advice I mean cuz you
know we can give out draconian advice
yeah you just have to get rid of all of
their stuff and force them to be
minimalist but of course that's not what
we think minimalism is about we don't
think there is a set template there
isn't a box that says here the the
hundred things you have to own and they
have to fit into this size space in
order for you to get your minimalism
card no minimalism is different for
different people and and it's going to
be different based on your values your
personal desires your personal needs and
your current living situation and for
people that have kids that means that
their living situation includes the kids
so like we have to set an example we
have to figure out what the outcome is
for the kids and you have to look at
other role model
who have done a phenomenal job I'll give
you one other essay title here from our
friend Leo and his wife Eva we had and
they're the ones with the six kids
we had him write an essay for our
website it's called a simpler family
life starting life anew with our six
kids and you can find that and he gives
some really great tips in there at the
minimalists comm slash Leo I'm gonna
recommend one more essay because some
people asked the question also like what
about my partner what if my partner how
do I make them a minimalist but we've
got this how isn't it a weird question
like yeah how do I force a person to
become a minimal man if we had that
answer we would write that book in
charge way more for our books can you
help me brainwash my partner right right
um so I would like to recommend another
essay it's a tote and the title of this
essay is minimalist families start with
yourself and you can find that at the
minimalist comm ford slash family but
ultimately that's what it talks about it
talks about how this journey it would be
amazing to have every friend and family
member become a minimalist but at the
end of the day you really need to start
with yourself yeah and at the bottom of
that essay there's another link to
twelve other articles about about being
a minimalist with a family so I think
you'll find a lot of value from that
well dawn and Steven and other dawn from
Twitter we're going to send you each a
autographed copy of everything that
remains it has a whole chapter in there
about the different flavors of
minimalism and minimalist families are
certain certainly a flavor that is worth
exploring I'll leave it with this you
know I think that it is much more
difficult when you have kids as I'm
learning to to be a minimalist it's
easier if you're by yourself but if you
have a partner or a spouse if you have
children it becomes much more difficult
but it becomes so much more in
at the same time amen what we'd love to
hear what you have to say so if you have
a comment about minimalist children or
if you have minimalism tips about how
you handle children any tips that you
might have then give us a call for zero
six two one nine seven eight three nine
I know some of you got some really good
tips out there and I'll lay in some
really bad tips we'd love to hear on
both but what I'll say is if you're
scared like I said this on last episode
if you are scared to call in because
you're worried that you're going to
sound inarticulate on the air I promise
you we have a really good editor no
matter how much you ramble we will make
you sound awesome on the air but please
call in and give us your comments yeah
and we'll air our favorite comments and
tips on the next episode if we do select
your voice mail we'll send you an
autographed copy of one of our books
either essential or minimalism live a
meaningful life or my personal favorite
everything that remains here's some
comments from our last episode hi my
name is Deb and I'm calling I want to
say hello you guys and also thank you
minimalism has changed my life
decluttering and only keeping was
essential and useful has made me a
happier calmer more peaceful person
my son is 16 and he sees the positive
impact that it brings thank you both for
sharing this concept of a simpler
lifestyle with us hey guys just wanted
to say I really enjoy your podcast I
really enjoyed the answer that you gave
to Evans question about cultivating
passions and so it really excited me the
idea of having a passion every 10 years
just as an example that you said hi guys
this is Laura from Amsterdam and yes I'm
calling from M for them like from
Holland to America but I don't care I
work at a coal company still I do and I
love my job
I'm a legal counsel and I know you're
not interested in what I do but what I'm
passionate about but I actually really
do love my job
I have comments on
the last podcast is what the girl was
caught slap while she was talking about
she likes strength and she wants to
follow them and what can she do without
using like shopping apps but for me it
would be pretty easy because I'm like
the same you have three things like
trend followers trendsetters and try and
watch it and actually when you follow
the shop your trend follow on both that
means you're kind of late so forehead
will be better to go just go down the
street and you don't have to be a
trendsetter just won't be a trend
watcher do it yourself and figure out
what might be the next trend and you
will be good at it and like well maybe a
month later or a year later depends on
if you're good at it or not if you have
a talent okay let's move on to our
iTunes comment of the week Ryan yes this
comes from DJ eighty this review is
titled awesome awesome DJ eighty writes
it's so refreshing I never realized how
bombarded with ads I was until I
listened to this ad free podcast well we
are really really glad that you
appreciate that we want to make sure we
add as much value as possible and yeah
we don't want to sell you a bunch of
crap we just want you to have what you
need you know it's interesting because I
listen to a lot of podcast and I feel
the same way
it's we used to okay there isn't
anything inherently wrong with
advertisers I think we should we should
just put that out there they can be a
bit dangerous though I mean if you
remember growing up in Ohio we had some
pretty terrible local advertisements
LaRosa's pizza remember that yeah four
seven one one one one
Bob's no big bugs carpet yes oh but
here's the thing like I never felt
compelled to go to big Bob's to to
purchase carpet I didn't feel like this
impulse to purchase immediately those
are terrible commercials and so they
weren't very dangerous at the time but
advertisements now man they're pretty
slick they're pretty good so much
sneakier advertisers do a great job
they're demographers who make
$250,000 a year $500,000 a year
to aggregate your eyeballs and your
eardrums to their advertisements and
they do a phenomenal phenomenal job of
it and you know I think I think that's
dangerous and so we have to be careful
of what we we put in in our lives
advertisements are going to be there
mm-hmm and you know we have to be able
to deal with that but at the same time
we didn't find it in line with our
values to put advertisements on this
podcast so thank you all for those of
you who do support our our podcast we
really really appreciate it and DJ 80
will go ahead and send you a copy of one
of our books what book should we should
we send DJ for saying that we're awesome
you know my favorites everything that
remains as well I mean that's by far the
best thing we've written yeah let's
let's end
let's send DJ a copy of everything that
remains and I just want to say thanks to
everyone else who has left a comment or
review on iTunes our podcast has reached
the top 30 of all podcast number two in
its category we really didn't expect
this like we hope that over time much
like our website it would grow and it
would catch on and more people would
listen to it but we didn't think that
tens of thousands or hundreds of
thousands of people at this point would
be listening to the podcast and we're
really grateful for you so thank you for
your reviews those reviews do help us
reach more people and we'll keep airing
our favorites we'll keep picking a
itunes comment of the week so feel free
to be really goofy or creative with your
itunes comments I'd love to see some
really crazy goofy ones in the coming
weeks
and Ryan if you're feeling like it I
would love to do a true lightning round
of questions and answers will do hashtag
ask the minimalists on twitter if you're
open to that okay if not we can we can
just not do it
no let's do it all right just I was just
thinking if I should plug in like all of
our social media stuff right now like a
job if you want to if you want to
contact us on social media we we are on
social media we have facebook.com slash
them
and then Instagram and Twitter we are at
the minimalists and this first question
from Fabio Fabio says hi hi you guys
and your essays there is no date how
would it be possible distinguished from
old essays and new essays I would say
you don't need to the content is
evergreen and it is just as applicable
today as it was five years ago when it
was written if we do need to put a date
in something we tend to otherwise we we
just don't have one I like to think what
we write is timeless Dean Jones writes
hashtag ask the minimalist please
include in the next podcast how to deal
with keeping stuff just in case oh just
in case well if you haven't heard of our
just in case rule you can check that out
on the minimalists comm /j I see yes you
know we think just in case are the three
most dangerous words in the English
language and so that essay is called
letting go of just in case items we have
a great rule called the 2020 rule will
let you read all about it there at the
minimalists comm justin asks hashtag ask
the minimalist what advice do you have
when it comes to buying a new
clutter-free home justin i think if
you're buying a home with clutter that's
probably a problem i think any new home
use purchase should be a hundred percent
clutter free Matt Taylor asks hashtag
ask the minimalist how would you best
declutter your life if your partner
enjoys material possessions is there a
compromise well certainly there's a
compromise but you have to ask yourself
that question what is my outcome and
ultimately it's about showing your
partner the benefits let's see here
click rights how can you minimize how
I'm sorry how can minimalism aid in the
recovery from addictions hashtag ask the
minimalists oh man that that's a big one
for me you know I when I was addicted to
drugs and alcohol it was because my life
was so overwhelmed I felt so overwhelmed
and it was very very stressful and once
I started to get the clutter out of the
way once I started to reprioritize not
only the things I was bringing to my
life but reprioritizing the people I
hung out with really really really
helped me to de-stress and it was a lot
easier to get help I'm not saying that
it was an easy road drug addiction of
any sort whether it's alcohol or heroin
all addictions are very very difficult
to get over I don't want to underplay
that but certainly cutting the
superfluous things out of your life is
going to help get through that a lot
faster at least it did for me yes yes
indeed Caitlyn asks at the minimalists I
want to clean out most almost everything
but my man does not he collects video
games help hashtag ask the minimalist
minimize them get rid of just kidding
don't blow it well it would but here's
what I'll say is you can't change the
people around you but you can change the
people around you sure rewind that back
and listen to it again and figure out
what I just said Caitlyn here's the
thing does your partner have the same
values as you and he just gets there a
different way can you show him the
benefits of minimalism
surround yourself with people have
similar values yeah does he love you
does he want you to be happy I'm sure he
does
and if that's the case then at the very
least maybe he will support you on your
journey maybe that doesn't mean he has
to have a packing party or that you're
gonna you know judge all of the things
that he has but you know maybe take that
approach and at least get get some
support
Daniel asks hashtag ask the minimalist
when you do a packing party what are the
rules to books you have already read my
rules I tend to get rid of them the
value is not in the book the value is in
the words themselves now I tend to hold
on the reference books that I am going
to go back and reference constantly I
was going to say that's the only books
that I've held on to a reference books
yeah but if you want to read how I got
rid of 2000 books and started reading
more you can go to the minimalists
dot-com
slash reading alright let's do a few
more here Kerry McKay says hashtag ask
the minimalist great podcast please
discuss whether a minimalist lifestyle
is an over controlled
lifestyle where is the balance point
well you know I had someone come up to
me at one of our events who said do you
find that minimalism is just a really
good excuse for people with OCD and you
know what I'll say is this is anything
taken to the extreme is is going to is
going to be a bad thing you can take
minimalism to the extreme you can take
maximalism to the extreme minimalism I
think helps us find that balance
but yeah if you take it to the extreme
and you deprive yourself then that
that's not necessarily a good thing
unless deprivation makes you happy I
don't know anyone who loves to be
deprived but if that's what it is that
makes you happy then go ahead and do
that but yeah certainly anything can be
taken to the extreme yeah minimalism is
not a radical lifestyle it is a
practical lifestyle abigail asks how do
you approach minimalism when your spouse
has no interest in owning less well you
find a way to approach it yourself start
with yourself and show others the
benefit yeah I'm just going to give that
link one more time the minimalist calm
forward-slash family it's an essay
titled minimalist family start with
yourself take a look at that okay let's
move on to our added value portion of
the show that's where we each recommend
something that has added value to our
lives now I am going to recommend
podcasts which is kind of weird because
this is a podcast you would think people
listen to podcast we've gotten so many
messages on on Facebook and and and
Twitter and Instagram and elsewhere
where people have said you know this is
the first podcast I've ever listened to
and I think that's why the show is doing
so well we have a lot of people who are
listening who were avid podcast
listeners like myself and you have
people who are relatively new to podcast
like you and sort of everything in
between and so we're getting the best of
both worlds here so if you're starting
with podcast you're finding some value
in them I'm going to just rattle off a
bunch that add value to my life
the first one I'm going going to mention
is a podcast that I listened to for
parenting advice because you know I'm
still learning a whole lot it's called
old mom and dad are fighting and it's
two folks from slate dan quois and and I
forget the Gala's name but it's an
awesome podcast because they get to
argue about different topics and they
get to talk about their triumphs and
their fails Alison Benedict is her name
by the way and they can talk about their
triumphs and their fails and what
they've done well what they haven't done
well they're fairly transparent about it
and they make recommendations I don't
know what is agree woods sometimes they
seem crazy to me but sometimes they're
just these gold nuggets that I'm able to
tweeze out and say yes that makes a lot
of sense I'm going to see if I can apply
that to my own life so check out mom and
dad are fighting if you want some some
parenting advice
now I listen to a bunch of different
podcasts all kinds of podcasts I really
ever make it through most of them if it
doesn't sound great to me if it doesn't
feel like a masterpiece I just move on
I've been doing a lot of physical
therapy lately for my back and so I've
had an opportunity to listen to hours
and hours of podcasts while I'm doing
that so I'm going to just rattle off a
few to you if you want some of our
favorites you can go to the minimalists
comm /fp
which stands for favorite podcasts and
here are some that may not actually be
on that list so I have fresh air with
Terry Gross most of you probably know
that radio show I have the New Yorker
podcast which is relatively new that
they change their format on it but a
bunch of pop culture stuff their pop
culture happy hour from NPR Dan Savage
Dan is the guy from whom we got the idea
to take calls for our podcast now just
just a warning he is he's a sort of a
sex advice columnist it's a little
raunchy on there sometimes yes he can
but a lot of the advice he gives out
it's good really great advice I mean
it's legitimate question so it's not
like he's just being raunchy for the
sake of it yeah and and so I really get
a lot of value from his podcast I really
appreciate his candor and his honesty
yeah i listened to neil degrasse tyson
he has a podcast called Startalk I
listened to the TED radio our TED radio
our sort of distilled some of the best
talks and puts them on a weekly radio
show slash podcast the very bad Wizards
I talked about that on the list actually
WTF with Marc Maron a really really
great show he has all kinds of different
people in there he had President Obama
on his podcast he does this this podcast
from his garage his house in the suburbs
of LA and they had President Obama on
there earlier this year and it was
hilarious could had snipers on the roof
of the neighbor's house across the
street and they had put like a whole
tent bubble around his house so he
literally records these podcasts in his
garage and has all kinds of big stars
and I was one of the biggest podcasts in
the world 99% invisible it's a design
show it's phenomenal let's see if I can
rattle off a few more here Bret Easton
Ellis one of my favorite authors has a
great podcast interviews a bunch of
different entertainers this is actually
was my introduction into podcasting he
was one of my favorite authors
throughout my 20s really inspired me to
write fiction and then he had this he
launched a podcast his very first guest
was Kanye West and he's had all kinds of
people on there since then Tom Sizemore
and all kinds of directors and and movie
stars etc the brilliant idiots loved
that show it really lives up to their
name it's mostly idiocy all the time but
there are nuggets of just pure
brilliance it's all pop culture stuff
though and I think in an alternate world
we probably could call our website and
our podcast brilliant idiots because
hopefully every once in a while you'll
get one nugget out of just one of these
episodes our gold our goal yeah our goal
and gold yes Dan Carlin has two podcasts
one I recommend won't recommend it on
the favorite podcasts si on our website
it's called hardcore history he is
basically the history professor you wish
you always had these are not podcasts
they are epic audio book events they'll
do for five hours series on World War
one so they'll do like 20 hours on World
War
amazing they are truly amazing he also
has a more political podcast called
common sense with Dan Carlin Joe Rogan
loved his podcast I don't know how he
does it he speaks for three hours at a
time and does like four or five podcasts
a week sometimes and just gets in there
and talks and talks and talks and keeps
it entertaining the whole time and has
some pretty interesting guests on his
podcast our friends Jessica and Melissa
have a phenomenal podcast called the
mind Palace they talk about what it
means to live a well curated life
they're both minimalists and they talk
from other sides of the pond so to speak
Jessica who helps us out with some of
our social media stuff on Facebook and
Twitter she does a phenomenal job there
her and Melissa chat about mindfulness
and living intentionally over at the
mind palace I'll leave it with these
last four they contrast each other a lot
so Real Time with Bill Maher and Glenn
Beck I listened to those back-to-back
one guy from the far left one guy from
the far right and it usually helps me
articulate a point in the middle if I'm
able to agree with 20 or 30 percent of
what Bill Maher saying and 10 to 20
percent of what Glenn Beck is saying I'm
able to form my own opinions about the
news of the week and and I find that it
gives me a balanced approach when I
listen to both sides and finally our
friends Rob Bell and Sam Harris both
have podcasts Rob bells a former pastor
who talks about spirituality and
religion and unconventional religion but
then our friend sam harris who is a
devout atheist has written several books
about atheism has a podcast called
waking up with sam harris where he talks
about spirituality without religion and
so I get to dip into both sides of the
aisle there we will try to do our best
to put all those podcasts in the show
notes for this episode as well I would
recommend just picking a few start out
with them see if you find value in them
and then move on from there
yeah my recommended value add for
today's podcast is right in line with
with you recommending podcasts
so I am new to podcasting when Josh came
to me like six months ago he's like you
listen to podcasts because I want to
start doing podcast so he gave me a few
recommendations I started listening to
them very quickly became frustrated with
the app that was on my phone wasn't a
very intuitive app so my recommendation
for all of you is this app called
overcast it is a great app to keep all
of your podcasts it's very intuitive and
what I like about it is you can speed it
up to one and a half times so those
podcasts that are super long it you can
get through them a little bit quicker it
sounds you know like they're talking
really fast like this but uh but once
once you get used to it it's makes a
huge difference so it is awesome right
but it's certainly an option and I do
that with longer podcasts and speed it
up to 1.2 or 1.5 and as I'm doing
physical therapy in 3 hours worth of
time I can I was very 2 hours with the
time I can listen to 3 hours worth of
podcast which is pretty amazing
I love overcast in fact I go out of my
way to support them because it's a
completely free app but they give you a
little donate option there and so I try
to donate I think it's you can do little
subscriptions or whatever it's like a
dollar a month to donate to them but
it's a completely free podcast but it is
the most beautiful most elegant and most
simple easy to use podcast app that I
have ever used and I've used several at
this point and none come close to
touching overcast that's for sure
finally let's move on to our last
segment it's what we call right here
right now this is where we we get to
talk about what's going on in the lives
of the minimalists that's us yeah man
we're going to Florida soon right well
by the time this airs actually I am
going to be on the sunny beaches of st.
Petersburg Florida and you all are
welcome to join me maybe not on the
beaches although if you see me there
make sure you say hi and I take it a hug
but that might be awkward for you but if
we're on the beach but you know what
we're going to do three caffeinated days
with the minimalists our friends
Joshua Weaver and Sarah Weaver this also
married couple who are responsible for a
lot of the photographs
on our book covers and our website etc
the actually the photograph for the
podcast is a photograph from Joshua
Weaver they are opening just an amazing
coffee shop called bandit coffee Co and
we wanted to help them out in some way
we love coffee it was our dream when we
left the corporate world to just be
baristas and then try to write part-time
and and we were I was really passionate
about writing fiction in particular and
I just wanted to get by and pay the
bills as being a barista and the website
kind of took off pretty quickly and
didn't get the chance to to go do that
and I'm really grateful for this
beautiful accident of the minimalists
but now we get to go work in a coffee
shop at least for a few days live in the
dream man amen
so we are spending three days in st.
Petersburg January 23rd through the 25th
we're screening the documentary our
documentary minimalism
a documentary about the important things
it's a special release charity screening
for our documentary where all the
proceeds go to orphan care where we're
building an orphanage in Honduras with
our friends over at the hope effect so
if you are in Florida or if you want to
travel to Florida right we have I've
already gotten messages from people in
in Georgia and Alabama now saying we're
going to make the trip down the st.
Peters but so if you want to make the
trip we're going to be there for three
days
unfortunately the December I'm sorry the
January 23rd event is sold out but so
that's the screening of the film it was
very limited in terms of tickets it sold
out in like crazy 24 hours before we
even put on our website it sold out we
just tweeted it out but we're going to
have 10 additional standing room only
tickets the day this podcast airs and
it's first-come first-serve it's
standing room only
but you'll have an opportunity to see
this documentary months before it comes
out in theaters later this summer after
that though on the 24th and 25th
completely free we're going to be
serving coffee to people
so we're going to be behind the counter
working at the coffee shop at Ben dick
Coffee Co you can find all the details
about this event including tickets and
you can RSVP to have us be your baristas
there that day are those two days
working at the shop if you just go to
the minimalists comm slash bandit RSVP
there it's completely free and 100% of
the tips go to the orphanage we're
building as well if you can't make it
there you can still contribute to the
orphanage till the end of this month at
the minimalists com
slash hope cool and let's not forget
about Tuesdays with the minimalists on
periscope we've been doing that we
started that a few weeks ago that's been
a lot of fun just kind of answering
these rapid-fire questions on periscope
we'll pull some stuff off of social
media with the hashtag ask the
minimalist and answer some stuff there
but this is a really cool way for people
to interact with us live you know it's
funny when all these like social new
social media platforms come out I
totally ignore them and I remember when
periscope first came out that came out
like what a year ago a year ago I just
remember it coming out thinking I'm
never going to use this I don't see the
value in this and then I started
watching how other people were using it
like Colin Ryder and any the other you
know people that were on there was doing
a phenom get off with it for a while
here's the guitar lessons with people
that is great that is so cool but that's
what's cool about that that application
is it allows you to interact in a live
setting it kind of like video Twitter in
a way maybe I don't know yeah it's it's
like live TV but on the phone and it's
not boring local live TV it's whoever
you want to follow and it's really neat
we've been doing this every Tuesday 7:00
p.m. Eastern Time throughout December
and January so you can still tune in in
fact we'll be in Florida so we might do
some beach time periscope Tuesday's with
the minimalist feel free to join us you
can find all the details on that at the
minimalists comm slash Tuesday and one
last thing I have this writing class
that I teach called how to write better
and I am doing a instead of doing that
the full semester where you you can take
I think it's 21 different video classes
a bunch of different
where's work I'm going to do a one day
to our online class to show people the
basics of how to write better and how to
establish that habit and some basic tips
and things I've learned over the years
and help people learn from my mistakes
and that's going to be on February 7th
and I think it's around 3 p.m. Eastern
Time you can find all the details on
this and how to write better dot-org we
mentioned the documentary stay tuned
we're going to do a tour around the
United States and Canada and May I think
we're doing something like 13 14 cities
at this point and we're also going to
that's going to be before it comes out
in theaters so comes out in theaters May
24 2016 and before that you're going to
get a chance to meet us we may even do
some live podcasts on the road in fact I
think when we're in Florida later this
month for three caffeinated days with
the minimal so we'll try to do a live
podcast at our events there as well but
we'll hit the road in May stay tuned to
our website in to the film's website
minimalism film comm for details and
pretty soon in February we're going to
tell you how you can bring minimalism a
documentary about the important things
to your city or your suburb yeah I've
seen a lot of people comment like oh
it's probably not going to come to my
city it's probably not going to come to
my theater and that is not true it can
through it'll absolutely come to your
city even if you're in I don't know give
me a random city Gary Indiana if you're
a Gary Indiana you could you could still
watch this film yes if you're in Eaton
Ohio bring it to eat in Ohio yeah
Chillicothe maybe details ago yeah
absolutely and and what I said earlier
you can't change the people around you
but you can change the people around you
I could tell you I have surrounded
myself these days with people who are
supportive and caring and we have
different personalities but we have
similar values we even have different
beliefs and I think it's important for
us to have people in our lives who
and allocate our time and resources to
those people and so we whoever were on
the road we have people ask us like it's
great that you were here for a day and
you had an event here I still these
people here at your event but how do we
connect with open-minded people locally
and we never had an answer for a long
time until we created something called
minimalist org it's free local meetup
groups brought to you by the minimalist
we don't want anything from you we just
wanted to create these meetup groups so
there's a hundred cities and eight
countries where we have groups meeting
once a month open-minded people give
your chance a give yourself a chance to
surround yourself with people who are
going to be supportive and and caring
and hold you accountable on whatever
journey you're taking whether that's a
decluttering journey or you're trying to
find your passion or your mission or
you're looking to have better
relationships better health a better
career you're looking for ways to grow
you're looking for ways to contribute
beyond yourself well this group can help
you do that yeah even if you're looking
for some support with the 30-day
minimalism game that's what I really
like seeing on these Facebook pages is
everyone supporting each other and oh
look what I got rid of today look you
know look what I got rid of yesterday
also a lot of cool things going on as
far as like tiny home tours special
guest speakers and different groups so
yeah check out a minimalist org
community in your area and see if
there's something there that piques your
interest yeah if there isn't one in your
area don't worry we've got you covered
there is an online city where we have
hundreds maybe even thousands of people
who meet online at this point and help
keep each other accountable online and
so you have both aspects here if you
have a local meetup group your group can
still interact with each other online we
have a Facebook group there where you
can join and it's absolutely free all
right Joe well we hope you certainly
found value in this episode and if you
leave here with just one message we hope
it's this love people and use things
because the opposite never works
that's it for today's episode Ryan you
want to read the important bits for us
sure thing
the minimalist podcast is produced by
Sean Harding and is recorded at the
office of asymmetrical press our theme
music was written and performed by Peter
Doran for more of Peters music visit the
minimalists dot-com slash Peter this
podcast is 100% advertisement free so if
you found value in this episode and
you'd like to help us keep it that way
because advertisements song please visit
the minimalists comm / donate even if
you just donate $1 we really really
appreciate it if you have a question for
the minimalists give us a call at four
zero six two one nine seven eight three
nine if you'd like to read more from the
minimalists you can subscribe to our
essays for free via email at our website
the minimalists comm thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine
about every little thing that you got
ahead every little thing that you guys
you gotta reach for you got a grand oh I
bet that you'll be fine without me
so tear your eyes or tea